basically just itch yes
bitching Jets hi everybody I'm Pete
Holmes and this is a five of my favorite
YouTube video clips on YouTube how do
you get when you get sick you know how I
get and if you haven't seen John John on
Sesame Street I mean you're welcome
my favorite one is where he hangs out
with Bert I believe it's called Bert's
lost paper clips
let me see you when you're saying yeah
that looks like sand to me you know it's
always good to get a refresher on your
range of emotions even as an adult he's
happy mad silly sad and when Bert lost
his paperclips he was angry I'm angry
paper clips he's very cute no joke I
have a framed still from this clip
hanging on my bedroom wall that's how
much I like it I'm happy yeah you're
happy yeah let me see were you when
you're happy ah another I love babies
laughing but I'm not including babies
laughing cuz you know but the one with
the five babies yeah alright sorry I'm
putting that on the list that is gonna
make you laugh now ready that'll get you
going and I also like guilty dogs so the
one that I'm gonna include is funny
guilty dogs compilation 2013 a very good
year for guilty dogs you lick everything
all the time non-stop I can't believe
that dogs they have a memory like they
know they did something wrong and then
they have a built-in protocol what they
do when they're feeling shame dogs feel
shame and people film it it's adorable
Thor what is this what did you do to the
shoe this one's a little bit more
esoteric I don't know if you'll like it
as much as I do but I like to watch game
shows from the nineties with children
video power is my go-to nobody remembers
video power but I do double dare it
isn't as good not enough time with the
kids interacting video power has a lot
of going into the audience like some
poor guy it's not the hose must be that
time to put their spot on John about
putting johnny on the spot the kids do
is they ask the host of the show
question 8 - how do you with the
quicksand do you know do you know yo
think about the 90s that's different
from now is now kids like know how to
find their mark you know any mean they
know that there's cameras and they're
like hi I'm Tommy I'm from Tulsa you
know I mean these kids are like oh
regular scared children it's the best on
teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles - way to
Shogun come from you just don't see that
anymore
you pop a tag on Jan you watch video
power I mean you'll write me a
handwritten thank-you letter and I'll
read it
hey man oh boy chips for that do we time
at home how does he called grandpa
alright my number 5 this is gonna sound
like a joke I like to watch clips of the
people show
hear me out it's not because I'm a
narcissist I am but it's not because I'm
a narcissist it's because we did so many
episodes of the talk show that I don't
remember it I have no idea where the
monologues going look at me I kind of
look like a lesbian Val Kilmer and the
host me in the past I'm like this guy is
my sense of humor exactly in fact I'd
like to imagine that there are millions
and millions of different universes each
slightly different from the last and
this universe the one we're all in
currently is the only one where I'm not
a youth pastor because it was all a blur
so now I get to watch it I'm like Batman
and Superman together I think it's time
we put our differences aside
and work together hey hey what I mean
why you're Batman
yeah did I have no special powers I
basically just yes bitchin debts
IP tomes those are five or so YouTube
videos that I watch that give me joy I
hope they give you joy and if they don't
congratulations you're the t800 robot go
find and kill Sarah Connor and before
you make fun I know for a fact Conan
does that too while smoking opium